wir kommen zu der zerrissenheit der
christen-union ich gucke in welche
kamera am besten in diese der cdu die ak
beklagte annegret kramp karrenbauer
beklagte in ihrer verhältnis ihrem
rücktritt ein ungeklärtes verhältnis
ihrer partei sowohl zu den linken als
auch zur afd
fangen wir vielleicht doch mal mit den
linken an schleswig holsteins
ministerpräsident daniel günther
schockierte seine cdu mit einer
unerhörten aufforderung mehr
pragmatismus im umgang mit den linken
wenn da vernünftige menschen in der
linkspartei am werk sind vertut man sich
nichts damit nach vernünftigen lösungen
zu suchen
es wäre gut auf scheuklappen zu
verzichten
die widerstände dagegen sind riesig es
geht um identität den markenkern der
union aber auch um ihre zukunft geht sie
so sehr um die linkspartei an der stelle
mir geht es etwa darum sind wir bereit
als cdu die miller willen zu akzeptieren
die linke ist auf bundesebene sicherlich
eine partei die nicht regierungsfähig
ist er sie hat auch in länder gezeigt
gerade in ostdeutschland dass sie mit
pragmatischer politik sehr wohl auch
arbeiten kann mit wem darf man reden mit
wem nicht eine koalition mit den linken
würde gleichbedeutend sein mit dem
anfang vom ende der volkspartei cdu
vielleicht würde ich noch einen schritt
weiter gehen als wäre das ende einer
volkspartei tobias hans hat daniel
günther ministerpräsident von schleswig
holstein als einziger westdeutscher
erkannt dass das kontaktverbot zur
linken die cdu im osten zerlegt also
trotz dieser formulierung habe ich
bislang schon den eindruck dass auch
daniel günther auf den beschlüssen
unsere parteitage steht die nämlich ganz
klar auch formuliert dass er mit der
linkspartei nicht zusammenarbeiten
können und dabei müssen wir auch bleiben
denn ich glaube es ist ganz wichtig dass
die menschen sich darauf verlassen
können dass wenn sie cdu wählen ihre
stimme eben nicht am ende in einer
regierung landet die mit der linkspartei
zusammenarbeiten und deswegen müssen wir
da klar sein und auch so deuten in
dieser politischen ausnahme situation in
thüringen auf das prinzip zu kochen ist
die richtige politische einfach
schauen sie frau illner natürlich ist
das ein riesiger fehler der passiert ist
was die zusammenarbeit mit der afg
anbelangt und ein fdp-mann sowie
natürlich das ist wirklich ein fehler
und das muss als solcher kennzeichen
wenn aber es ist doch deswegen auch kein
grund dass wir uns auf der anderen seite
öffnen für eine zusammenarbeit mit der
linkspartei was zu uns programmatisch
überhaupt gern einem bundesland zentrale
aussage auch in einem bundesland kuban
ist dran mit der frage dass selbst der
altbundespräsident joachim gauck sich in
die bresche warf und er ist wirklich
nicht dafür bekannt die kommunisten
umarmen zu haben und hat irgendwie immer
abstand gehalten zudem dass die cdu in
thüringen über ihren schatten springen
sollte wird er also aus meiner sicht ist
klar wir sind die partei von helmut kohl
und die partei von der merkur ist die
partei der wiedervereinigung wir sind
diejenigen die es immer vorangetrieben
haben gegen viele widerstände und
deswegen können wir nicht mit leuten wie
ein ramelow zusammenarbeiten der sich
hinstellt und bis heute nicht die ddr
als unrechtsstaat bezeichnen kann den
schießbefehl in zweifel zieht der
schießbefehl der übrigens vom bgh
bestätigt worden ist in einem urteil
gegen den ehemaligen ddr
verteidigungsminister heinz keßler und
wo zum beispiel auch jemand wie ein
innenpolitischer sprecher der
landtagsfraktion in thüringen ehemaliger
offizier der ddr grenzpatrouille ist von
daher das sind leute wo ich auch sage da
wieder verlassen wir unsere zehn minuten
und deswegen sagen wir wir können mit
denen ich zusammenarbeite
war ja relativ einfach nämlich sich die
frage zu stellen ob er eine gefahr für
die demokratie ist heute ist ja dass ich
würde sagen es geht nicht um die frage
wer schlimm ist und wer schlimmer ist
sondern es geht um die frage mit wem er
unser partner sein kann und wer nicht
unser partner sein kann
und für uns ist klar wir arbeiten nicht
mit herrn röcke und wir arbeiten nicht
mit herrn ramelow zusammen wir werden
den rahmen nicht will weil es am ende
der cdu dna widerspricht und deswegen
sage ich wir brauchen einen
parteiunabhängigen ministerpräsidenten
der uns aus dieser verzwickten situation
in thüringen
der hohle die ältesten argumente an was
sie wieder praktiziert haben ist die
gleiche
[Applaus]
wenn sie dich sein das ist sein dass ein
fehler wenn sie jetzt mal kurz durch ein
gerade hallo gerade herr ramelow hat
sich immer wieder sehr klar und kritisch
mit dem unrecht in der ddr
auseinandergesetzt und natürlich ich
wollte von hans in einem punkt recht
geben
cdu und linke wollen für dieses land
unterschiedliche wege
das gehört zu einer lebendigen
demokratie dazu eine gepflegte
kontroverse auch unterschiedliche
interessen sozusagen zwischen
demokratischen parteien niemand also ich
rede ja auch nicht das wort das man
jetzt eine art liebeshochzeit zwischen
linken und union nein wir wollen
unterschiedliche richtung aber in
thüringen sind hier in einer
ausnahmesituation und eine partei die in
thüringen bereit war ein weg den die afg
von röcke vorgeschlagen hat mit zu gehen
hat eine krise herbei geschaffen wo es
jetzt ein park mathis muss braucht wie
wir damit umgehen müssen und deswegen
sagen wir noch nicht wir brauchen nicht
eine gemeinsame regierung wir werden auf
bundesebene glaube ich auch weiterhin
heftig miteinander sozusagen streiten
was ist der richtige weg
ich wär bewerbe für ein weg der sozial
und ökologisch und demokratisch ist aber
in thüringen haben eine ausnahme
situation und da muss man jetzt
rauskommen
[Applaus]
modulrahmen wie cds bodo ramelow ein
typischer linker arbeit weiter bayerns
ich kann jetzt nicht beurteilen werden
typische und wenn nicht typischer linker
ist bodo ramelow ist ein vertreter der
linken und er ist sicher eines er ist
demokratisch gewählt das gilt im übrigen
für afd auch aber bodo ramelow steht
dann auch zum zur verteidigung der
demokratie und das ist der große
unterschied bei der afg die afg lässt
sich demokratisch wählen die nutzer
rechtsstaatliche prinzipien um dann die
demokratie zu untergraben menschen
verächtlich zu machen und das ist doch
ein riesenunterschied
und sie haben sie sich eigentlich waren
sie haben wir sehen sie hat ein problem
sie haben übersehen sie habe nie bereit
problem da sind schon lange mit liegen
sagt ich jetzt haben beziehungen haben
kein problem damit dass die blockflöten
der ost-cdu dass sie die damals
übernommen haben erinnern sich
vielleicht nicht mehr dran das war ein
teil quasi des sed-regimes mitsamt
vermögen mit allen strukturen hat die
cdu oder und personal
die bis heute in der politischen in der
politischen programmen geben sich
bemerkbar machen im osten so und dann
kommen sie und sagen jetzt auf einmal
dass die die spd hat das nicht gemacht
ist vielleicht heute ihre struktureller
nachteil aber auf der anderen seite
lassen sie sich darauf ein mit mit dem
am ende zu taktieren dass die afg
bestimmt wer ministerpräsident wird und
sie sind nicht in der lage eine der
unternehmer sind ja gerne korrigieren
indem sie sagen dann bringen wir jetzt
den dem präsident ministerpräsidenten
der fünf jahre gemacht hat und er alles
andere als eine gefahr für die
demokratie war dass er wieder ins amt
kommt um neuwahlen auszuschreiben
dann machen sie das doch machen sie den
einen die eine korrektur dass sie die
die linke als partei nicht wollen dass
die person vielleicht nicht wollen ist
alles in ordnung gehört zur demokratie
aber diese nicht
die sind gleich dran gehen noch mal ganz
kurz beide robin alexander zu es gibt
eine cdu ministerin in schleswig
holstein die heißt karin prien und die
sagt die linke als politischer gegner
die afg als politischer feind klingt
eigentlich gar nicht so kompliziert
ja ich weiß nicht ob die die
innerstaatliche feind erklärung eine
besonders gute idee ist wenn man gegen
rechts argumentieren will aber das
personal beiseite das sind doch
pappkameraden also das letzte mal hat
die afg am letzten mal hat die cdu am
freitag im präsidium beschlossen keine
zusammenarbeit mit der linkspartei wir
wählen denn ramelow nicht das war
freitag zu samstag war der
koalitionsausschuss im
koalitionsausschuss kamen die cdu
bundeskanzlerin auf die idee herrn
ramelow anzurufen sie endlich dazu das
lehnen die von herrn dobrindt er nämlich
als einziger die nummer vor den rahmen
und gespeichert hat und stimmt und sie
könnte mir bestimmt ist das stimmt nicht
so und also die cdu kanzlerin ruft den
ramelow an und macht mit ihm aus wie
können wir erreichen dass sie wieder
ministerpräsident werden und dann zu
neuwahlen kommen ein und am ertrag feuer
wird das andere beschlossen also das ist
doch nicht ernst zu nehmen also da muss
man schon bei der wahrheit bleiben
alexander wurde es wurde angebot den
anruf sich erklären wie man den
rücktritt von herrn kemmerich
ermöglichen kann
betragen im weg und das teurer werden
und deswegen auf gar keinen fall darum
herrn ramelow zum ministerpräsidenten zu
wählen und ich will das mal sehr
deutlich sagen es gibt einen meilen
breiten unterschied zwischen der
linkspartei und der afd
und das muss man sicherlich anerkennen
und trotzdem ist es unredlich wenn sie
sich jetzt sozusagen als die
säulenheiligen der demokratie hier
aufstellen herr ramelow wusste genau wie
im übrigen auch die abgeordneten der cdu
und der fdp der spd und den grünen grün
das ist keine mehrheit gibt im landtag
in thüringen
und trotzdem hat heute am loh sich sogar
geschulte mehrheit aber schauen sie
wahlsieger herr ramelow hat sich als
einziger bezeichnet weil sie haben im
parlament eine mehrheit
er hatte keine mehrheit
trotzdem direkt an frau kopp macht es
sinn in im jahr 2020 die linken noch so
zu dämonisieren dämonisieren für die cdu
ich glaube die cdu hätte gut daran getan
vor den strategisch wichtigen
landtagswahlen eine strategie zu
überlegen oder einen plan b der sie
ermöglicht hätte mehrheits optionen oder
zumindest gestaltungsoptionen auszuloten
und diese unvereinbarkeit beschlüsse
lassen das einfach nicht zu also man
hätte sich doch vorstellen können
man macht konkrete vorschläge geht mit
denen an die rot rot grüne
minderheitsregierung heran und dann wäre
ramelow mehr oder weniger eben auch ein
ministerpräsident gewesen der im hohen
maße von den inhaltlichen optionen der
cdu angewiesen sagt die
wissenschaftlerin vorherige übrigens
wieder die experten regierung ins
gespräch bringt muss ich dazu was sagen
sie wissen doch auch das zum ersten mal
in thüringen dieser vorschlag der
experten regierung in einem brief den
der auf dem anhänger an kemmerich
geschrieben hat gefallen ist und wenn
wir mit dieser frage jetzt immer wieder
dieses modell aus marokko und wissen ist
und wenn sie jetzt immer wieder von
experten reden wir können doch einfach
mal sagen
in thüringen haben die amateure bei fdp
und cdu jede menge schaden angerichtet
da kann man doch jetzt einfach mal die
probeweise super dass sie sie haben in
die nächste runde
wenig schaden wie möglich letzte frage
in dieser hinsicht sie haben gesagt sie
wollen nicht entscheiden was das
kleinere übel ist oder das übel ist in
einer solchen situation wo man nur
wählen konnte zwischen herrn ramelow und
herrn röcke würden sie da nicht
wenigstens sagen herr ramelow wäre das
kleinere übel
also erst einmal sage ich wir haben für
uns klare leitplanken gesetzt weil wir
gesagt haben
die arbeit ich nicht mehr arbeiten aber
wir arbeiten nicht als partei von helmut
kohl mit denjenigen zusammen die die sed
erben sind die nachfolgepartei der sed
sind und wir arbeiten auf der anderen
seite nicht ihre einschätzung nach in
seinen shops und deswegen nein wir
werden aber nicht mit denen
zusammenarbeit es geht um die frage der
glaubwürdigkeit sind wir als cdu
glaubwürdig und wenn wir sagen wir
wollen mit beiden nicht dann können sich
die wähler darauf verlassen und darauf
sollen sich auch in zukunft verlassen
deswegen haben wir diesen und
vereinbarkeit beschluss und er gilt und
er wird auch in zukunft gelten und er
gilt auch für die wahl von bodo ramelow
gab es gedankenspiele barrymore in eine
projekt regierung mit der linken zu
machen oder gab es die nicht
es gab einzelne projekte die
identifiziert wollen die man unterstützt
hätte aber es ging nicht um die frage ob
man eine ramelow mit wäre es ging um die
frage ob man projekte einer stimme die
natürlich unter dem ende schon ende
wissen sie auch sie arbeiten
beispielsweise in einzelnen stadträten
wie beispielsweise auf rügen mit der afg
zusammen es gibt beispielsweise bei mir
am stadtrand barsinghausen habe schon
erlebt dass die spd mit der afg sachen
durchgeboxt hat und deswegen würde ich
ihnen rannten so den moralischen
zeigefinger zu heben weil sie mich
genauso abgerissen
die frage dazu nebenher alexander wie
löst man das politisch jetzt auf gibt es
überhaupt die möglichkeit zu sagen wir
verständigen uns auf den oder den oder
muss es irgendein demokratische
abgewählt abgeordnete abgewählte ein
demokratischer abgeordneter aus dem
thüringischen landtag sein es wäre schon
gut wenn ein demokrat mich natürlich
mehrere möglichkeiten die experten
regierung ist doch nicht verbrannt war
der ärger dass man im mund genommen
würde man sicher abhängig machen
von diesen leuten natürlich dass wir ja
auch der logische nächste schritt wenn
man sagen würde es gibt keinen der im
landtag die mehrheit kriegt dann würde
man einen neben auf die man sich einige
könnte und einen strukturierten prozess
hätte aber natürlich könnte man auch
sagen die cdu enthält sich im 3
gang oder mehrere ist herr ramelow oder
wenn die wellen häuser würde die welt
auch nicht untergehen
aber und da würde ich der frau
professorin widersprechen es gab ja noch
eine weile im osten in sachsen und da
hat die cdu die kante zur afg noch
härter gezogen und auch die kante zur
linkspartei
noch härter gezogen und das ergebnis war
dass die demokratische mehrheit
hingekriegt haben weil das problem ist
doch wenn man die ganzen geschichtliche
moralischen debatten weglässt herr
mohring hat erst versucht nach links zu
öffnen und dann haben leute in der cdu
versucht mit rechts zusammen jemand
anders zu werden wenn sie jetzt
thüringer wähler sind kreuzen sie die
cdu an wenn da vielleicht ramelow und
vielleicht jemand mithört herauskommen
können das wissen sie doch nicht tun
das tut doch niemand wenn sie aber
wissen sie kriegen die cdu vielleicht
mit der spd mit den grünen aber dann
nicht dann ist das für sie eine option
und deshalb glaube ich dass langfristig
die klare kante für demokratische
mehrheiten besser ist und man es eben
auch mal in die opposition gehen wenn
man merkt dass man nicht regieren kann
das gehört eben auch zur wahrheit dann
hätte das heißt dann hätte michael rohr
in die opposition gehen sollen ja man
hätte in die opposition gehen sollen
weil er die wahl verloren hat und das
muss man auch anerkennen und herr
ramelow hätte weil er keine mehrheit im
parlament hat eben als ministerpräsident
im amt bleiben können dass sie die
thüringische verfassung vor und hätte
dann sich zu einzelnen sachverhalten im
parlament auch mehrheiten suchen müssen
so ist das ein elementares regierung hat
vor anderen wirklich noch mal erinnern
und da wären wir haben in thüringen sie
auch ganz andere türen über ganz andere
mehrheiten als in sachsen das stimmt ja
in thüringen ist es so dass es wenn man
die afg nicht möchte ohne die linken
keine mehrheit gibt also jetzt alle
anrufe dass sich der spd grüne fdp und
cdu zusammen tun sollen putz- oder gibt
es einfach nicht da halte ich mich das
meinte ich mit die westdeutschen
mehrheiten gibt es so im osten nicht
mehr
und das kann das was in thüringen
passiert ist das ist nicht möglich da
sollen sich darauf gut ist das ist
wirklich eine bösartige unterstellung
ich stelle analysiere doch nur das ist
eine deutliche veränderung in pattaya
schlimm
zumal die debatte zusammen ist positiv
unsere bürger ist doch jetzt sagen kann
sowohl an den unterschied machen
zwischen der afg und der linken und dann
trotzdem wenn ich sie richtig zu
zitieren
mit beiden nicht zusammen arbeiten
schauen wir noch mal auf das andere
fällt nämlich die abgrenzung innerhalb
der cdu nach rechts und auch damit haben
in aller erster linie die cdu ost
verbände ein problem für die csu ist
ganz klar ist dafür überhaupt kein
zweifel geben dass es wie immer eine
geartete zusammenarbeit duldung oder
auch nur eine tolerierung durch eine afd
geben könnte für die einen eine klare
sache für andere realitätsverlust über
freunde kommt aus ihrem elfenbeinturm in
berlin oder in münchen endlich mal
runter kommt raus kommt an die basis und
guckt euch an wie es wirklich aussieht
ich kann keine 25 prozent der
wählerinnen und wähler einfach vom kopf
stoßen und sagen mit euren vertretern
rede ich nicht was ihr wollt was er sagt
ist mir völlig egal berliner denkverbote
auch andere wollen sie nicht weiter
akzeptieren
thüringens fraktionsvize michael heim
es gibt in diesem neu gewählten landtag
auch eine bürgerliche mehrheit denn cdu
fdp und afd haben eine mehrheit von 48
stimmen die cdu nach rechts zu rücken
ist ziel der so genannten werte union
ein krebsgeschwür es manche in der
parteispitze 4000 mitglieder hat die
werte union darunter ex
verfassungsschutzpräsident maßen ein
bündnis mit der afd
eine cdu muss auch personen aushalten
können die andere meinung haben
ich sehe es etwas lockerer was gespräch
angeht ich sage immer man muss mit allen
menschen reden der flirt mit recht
eine zerreißprobe für die letzte
volkspartei themen kuba zu werte union
kommen wir gleich erstmal michael heim
aus thüringen afd ist eine konservative
partei zählt zum bürgerlichen lager und
herr zimmer in sachsen anhalt das sind
zwei fraktionschefs also auch nicht
irgendjemand in der cdu was ist
eigentlich mit ihren brandmauern
bröckeln die nicht überall
wir haben den klaren beschluss dazu
gefasst und jeder der das jeder der das
anders sieht der soll ein antrag auf dem
bundesparteitag der cdu stellen und dann
werden wir darüber diskutieren dann
werden wir einen beschluss fassen oder
eben nicht anders fassen ich bin mir
sehr sicher dass 99 prozent der
cdu-mitglieder das genauso sehen wie wir
das wirkt eine klare brandneue haben
nach rechts und nach links noch mal ganz
konkret im nächsten jahr sind in sachsen
anhalt wahlen wenn sich diese partei die
cdu sachsen anhalt genau so verhält wie
ihr stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender dann haben sie ein
identisches problem wie in thüringen
also wenn ich einen ratschlag geben darf
ich halte mich da eigentlich gerne auch
zurück aber ich würde der cdu in sachsen
anhalt klar und deutlich mit auf den weg
geben macht sowie michael kretschmer
führt einen klaren abgrenzungskurs nach
rechts und nach links und die welt
erfolgreich seien die verben höcke wählt
oder gewählt hat ist der wieder für die
cdu rückt zurückgewinnen also es wird
sicherlich sehr schwer sein weil man
einfach feststellen muss dass gerade die
jahren hätte jemand ist der nicht nur
ganz weit rechts steht sondern der auch
tatsächlich falsch ist es der nazis der
sich der ns sprache bedient der von
umvolkung spricht an anderen
unerträglich keiten so jemand ist von
jemandem der christdemokrat ist im
herzen nicht wählbar
ich will nicht ausschließen dass es
menschen gibt die nicht nachgedacht
haben ich will nicht ausschließen dass
es menschen gibt die auch aus protest
gewählt haben und um die müssen sich
alle demokratischen parteien noch mal
bemühen und sein
da gibt es auch noch eine andere heimat
aber völlig klar ist wer mit bahn höcke
zusammenarbeit
der passt nicht zur cdu und das muss man
jedem auch sagen da müssen wir uns ganz
klar abgrenzen als christdemokraten denn
sonst verlieren sie die iwl angefragt
die abgrenzung zur fdp ist das eine
problem das andere problem ist die werte
union innerhalb der cdu auch wenn das
natürlich eigentlich keine organisation
ist die zu den verdi zur partei selbst
gehört es ist ein verein hans-georg
maßen haben wir zitiert das war einer
der wichtigsten staatsbeamten
deutschlands heute ist er mitglied der
werte union wollen sie mitglieder wie
ihn ausschließen annegret kramp
karrenbauer hatte das wahl angedeutet
hätte sie ihn tatsächlich nicht nur
kritisieren sollen sondern in die gehen
müssen ist das alles zu spät
also es wäre auf jeden fall das beste
wenn hans georg maas in seinem
parteibuch in der cdu hergeben würde
dann wäre mit der afg paktiert wer mit
der hfg zusammenarbeiten will hat keinen
platz in der union
ich bin um ehrlich zu sein kein freund
von ausschlussverfahren die am ende sehr
kritisch ablaufen und dafür sorgen dass
die person gar nicht mehr erkannt wird
wenn es soweit ist also ich glaube wenn
man heute eine umfrage gemacht und der
jungen menschen wäre es thilo sarrazin
erinnern sich die wenigsten mehr dran so
lange hat das gedauert hinaus der ist
aus der spd auszuschließen das ist für
mich kein vorbild wir müssen aber klar
sein ob sie in unserer ansage dass wir
dass wir das nicht dulden dass es nicht
zur union passt hans-gerd maßen spricht
nicht für die cdu und michael kretschmer
gerade entlassen sehr klar in dieser
frage ob ihn alex mit ihren kurven
richtig sagt hat eine wahl gewonnen mit
dieser klang her klar und deutlich mehr
einfach von eurem fatale freuen wir
reden über die werte union robin
alexander ist eben in den augen der
werte union die afg so etwas wie die cdu
nur mit weniger flüchtlinge also wenn
sie die leute fragen sagen die immer sie
würden sich damit beschäftigen wie man
die afg kleiner kriegen würde und sie
wollen die cdu recht nach rechts rücken
damit ja auf die kleiner wird dass es da
auch einzelne gibt die an
bündnisoptionen glauben
das denke ich kann man auch sagen ich
finde nur immer so die karrieren sind ja
erstaunliche deutsche und hans georg
maas der verfassungsschutz chef und
seine karriere hat unter otto schily als
otto schily der sozialdemokrat
innenminister war
da wurde herr maßen der mann der hier
den ganzen apparat aufbauen musste im
gegen islamisten usw
also wenn jemand auf denen hat ein
sozialdemokratischer innenminister sein
vertrauen setzt jetzt schon nicht mehr
in die cdu passt das will ich eine
erstaunliche entwicklung aber die frage
der kann sich ja verändert haben kann
man ja alles sagt sie doch selber wäre
oder das interessiert wie hier sagt er
auf jeden fall der richtige wegen dieser
geschichte war auch nicht alles einfach
nicht hätte irgend jemand interessiert
mich hätte irgendjemand der aspiranten
auf den neuen cdu vorsitz ab und
vielleicht kanzlerkandidat
das problem von thüringen anders gelöst
als es gelöst worden
das problem von thüringen war doch nicht
das problem von annegret
kramp-karrenbauer das wäre doch wirklich
unfair
dieser receiver cdu es doch entstanden
2015 mit der flüchtlingspolitik und
jetzt gibt es tatsächlich
unterschiedliche ideen wie man den
heilen könnte und auch frau carmen
karrenbauer hat ja versucht auf diese
skeptiker der migrationspolitik
zuzugehen und ein werkstattgespräch
gemacht alle ins adenauer haus
eingeladen was die kanzlerin gar nicht
so gut vermehrt sagt er kann die hälfte
der afg la zurückholen und ersparen
würde sicherlich sagte schenker ich
berichte dass also vermietet nehmen und
ersparen er hat ja eine nachgewiesene
frühe skepsis gegenüber 2015 geäußert da
müssen die sich alle erproben aber dass
der kurs diese leute einfach rechts
liegen zu lassen dass der nicht mehr
weiter geht darin würde ich mich schon
versteigen war das bild der brand war
was wird glaube ich niemand mehr draußen
noch hören kann heißt doch draußen ist
ein feuerwerk eine brandmauer und dann
müsste man darüber reden wie löscht man
wie so oft ist das nicht ein informant
noch mal herr cuba si
haben das verfolgt die werte union hat
der kanzlerin ja immer vorgeworfen dass
sie die cdu insgesamt zu sehr nach links
gerückt hat sagt es nur die werte union
würden sie das nicht auch sagen also
erst einmal muss man sagen ein einsatz
als hans-georg maßen recht das
wertkonservative innerhalb der cdu am
platz haben und das ist auch in zukunft
so aber wir brauchen dafür keine flügel
gruppierung sondern wir haben am ende
drei wurzeln aus dem wir bestehen dem
christlichsozialen dem
wirtschaftsliberalen und dem
konservative flügel und genau die werden
wir auch in zukunft mehr stärken und die
werden wir mehr einbinden und da gibt es
sicherlich auch leute dabei innerhalb
der partei die vielleicht auch mit einer
ausrichtung mal nicht zufrieden sind
aber das entscheidet am ende die
mehrheit in einer partei so der weise
wie die presse mit musik würdigen hatte
sich genau an den verfassungsschutz ist
darüber diskutieren was antworten sie
informiert sind
frau merkel und ihre flüchtlingspolitik
auch schuld daran dass die afg so stadt
wurde
es ist klar dass wir am ende eine
flüchtlingspolitik gemacht haben die
natürlich auch raum gelassen hat und
dass wir dort die möglichkeit gegeben
haben dass auch eine partei rechts der
union entstehen kann
das ist sicherlich in der tat auch so
aber diese entscheidung ist damals
getroffen worden und die entscheidung
ist nicht alleine von angela merkel
getroffen worden das kann man am ende
auch eben nicht so einfach und so kurz
sagen sondern sie es getroffen worden in
der cdu die macht man gut wenn die
marschrichtung das ist immer so in einer
partei es gibt auch viele dinge die ich
gut finde es gibt viele dinge die
vielleicht weniger wieso ist es im leben
so ist das in einer volkspartei noch mal
mehr als in einer klinik hatte und vor
allem haben wir das zu wenig diskutiert
in der cdu das muss man ja auch mal noch
mal sagen oder lange phase der region
wurden die stadt gefragt an den stellen
wo hat man es wirklich intensiv man
nochmal lebendig miteinander besprochen
das ist zu kurz gekommen und aus welche
stadt köln ist über diese chance jetzt
nutzen bevor es wirklich als volkspartei
zu spät ist und deswegen geht es hier
nicht um personalfragen allein sondern
es geht wirklich um die zukunft der cdu
als volkspartei aber es ist so wie wenn
friedrich merz sagt nehmen wir doch mal
an herr bosbach und ich wären in der
bundesregierung gewesen dann wäre die
fdp heute
dieser form nicht existent naja man kann
ich auch sogar beweis wird nicht
angetreten werden das erst mal beweisen
wie viel wie wir über nimmt man dann
selbst an positionen also ich meine es
nützt ja nichts wenn man die afg dadurch
verhindert dass man selber ein stück auf
die wir so fähig gemacht als spd dann
müssen sie uns keine belehrung ergeben
hat so sagen herr hans die koalition in
den rot rot regiert hat können sich was
den schutz und die verteidigung von
demokratie angeht jedem vergleich
stellen und das hat man muss ja schon
mal noch sagen können dass die
linksparteien ganz anderes verhältnis
zum eigentum hat wie zum beispiel die
spd die und trotzdem machte sie dicht
miteinander ist wirklich schwierig
irgendwann sind sie für
industriearbeiter nicht mehr den gerade
darüber ist dass weniger manchmal auch
auf den inhalt an
herr walter borjans spd hat überhaupt
kein problem mit der abgrenzung zu afd
auch die linkspartei nicht das wissen
wir haben diese wähler auch kein problem
sind nicht auch wähler der spd zur afg
gewann ja und zwar das ist genau der
punkt ich stimme herrn hans zu dass wir
uns bei den wählern darum kümmern müssen
welche welle haben sich leimen lassen
das muss man ganz klar sagen damit dass
die afg eine soziale maske aufsetzt sie
versucht doch themen anzugehen die jeden
menschen umtreiben von der wohnung über
den arbeitsplatz über die rente und all
diese dinge also man kann am ende sagen
es hat was national soziales und mit all
dem was daraus auch wird und worum es
worauf es ankommt ist menschen zu sagen
wisst ihr eigentlich worauf ihr euch ein
lasst das ist vielen offenbar entweder
nicht bewusst oder sie spielen was wir
ja häufiger heute haben mit dem risiko
um mal zu sehen was denn passiert weil
man mittlerweile kann mehr glaubt
deswegen hat das natürlich auch was mit
unserer glaubwürdigkeit zu tun
und deswegen ist es auch so wichtig an
dieser stelle glaubwürdig zu bleiben und
keine keinen fußbreit von rational zu
der andere name in der runde frau kopp
nennt friedrich merz sich hinstellt und
sagt mit mir halbiert sich die afg in
ihren zustimmungs zahlen wird er das
schaffen
das ist eine steile these die er in der
konkurrenz mit anderen mitbewerbern
formuliert worden ist und dir
wahrscheinlich nicht einhalten kann
denn es handelt sich ja nicht nur um
protestwähler sondern mittlerweile gibt
es eben auch eine bindung an diese
partei und auch eine zustimmung zu den
jeweiligen positionen man kann
vielleicht verunsicherte wähler wieder
zurückholen aber halbieren würde ich
sagen dafür ist die situation zu komplex
als dass man das tatsächlich in die
politische debatte als pfund einbringen
kann und solchen markt ist eine
gemeinsamkeit zwischen allen
demokratischen parteien dass wir
natürlich alle die pflicht um jeweils in
unserem bereich um die eigenen wähler zu
kämpfen die frage ist und das ist glaube
ich der dissens zwischen uns niemand das
macht macht man es in dem man sich mal
vorurteile hetze gegen einzelne
menschengruppen etwas freundlicher
vielleicht ist die afg aber bedient oder
indem man die af deren antrag gestellt
und ich würde es man das indem ich zum
beispiel nicht sie in dem ich zum
beispiel darauf hinweise dass die afg
erst vor kurzem die spende bekommen hat
von dem bauinvestor und deswegen jetzt
voller energie im sie stark macht
gegenmaßnahmen wie den mieten deckel die
bezahlbares wohnen für die menschen an
sichert und im kampf um bezahlbare
mieten möchte ich die afg stelle nicht
indem man versucht in die irre hätten
jetzt kommt hier noch mal eine frage zur
cdu frau kipping hat angela merkel in
ihren augen die cdu modernisiert oder
entkernt ich glaub angela merkel ist
einfach ein produkt ihrer zeit gewesen
es hat in dieser situation eine
modernisierung gegeben in vielerlei
hinsicht und daraufhin gibt es eine
konterrevolution von rechts das hat
weniger als weniger der verdienst von
angela merkel sondern ich glaube das ist
der verdienst der zivilgesellschaft und
konkurrent noch mal herr alexander und
meine cdu in deutschland wurde
mindestlohn wieder abschafft die
hochzeiten von lesben und schwulen
wieder verbinden verbietet die
atomkraftwerke wieder anschaltet würde
die noch über 30% falter die jungs
verpasst ottorino können von den krisen
gefordert das hat mir an ihm entstanden
dieses rad wieder zurückdrehen hat sich
die gleiche frage hat sie ihre partei
modernisiert oder mr
natürlich hat angela merkel die cdu
modernisiert
das ist ja jetzt auch schon ein bisschen
was her und vielleicht ist die
entwicklung eines wieder ein stück
weiter wenn man sich anguckt zum
beispiel was in österreich passiert ist
da hat die christdemokratische partei
jemand übernommen der sie hart
profilierter verkettung würde sagen
schlimmen nach rechts gerückt und jetzt
ist in einer koalition mit den grünen
und sagt man kann sowohl das klima
schützen als auch die grenzen
also vielleicht gelingt es ja profil
aufzubauen und profil aufbauen ist etwas
anderes als hetze also da müsse man
wirklich auch mal trend schafft
argumentieren und gleichzeitig
anschlussfähig in anderen milieus zu
werden und auch noch eine modernisierung
zu bringen warum soll das eigentlich im
widerspruch sein
wenn frau kopf tatsächlich die
politischen auseinandersetzungen morgen
nicht mehr bei ard und linken in aller
erster linie zu hause sind sondern ganz
woanders gefällt werden nämlich bei
schwarz-grünen bündnissen wird sich dann
automatisch auch die diskussion über die
abgrenzung zur linken und zur afd
verkleinern
das glaube ich nicht also denn wir
werden das mit der afg weiterhin zu tun
haben und die die linkspartei hat ja
auch ihren platz im politischen system
im parteiensystem fest gewonnen und kann
ja auch beachtliche wahlerfolge erzielen
also nein das ist nicht vorbei und auf
landesebene wird sie weiterhin sehr
bunte koalition geben die diese fragen
weiter ihre länder halten abzutun
sodann jetzt noch eine wohlfühl frage
herr kuban mit wem könnte schwarz-grün
leichter werden mit herrn laschet
spielfrei oder françois dabei eigentlich
sie können ein beantworten davon denkt
da also wir sind offen aber erstmal
kämpfe dafür dass wir als cdu nicht
gekauft werden dass wir die stärkste
kraft in deutschland werden
das ist unser anspruch und was danach
für bündnisse möglich sein müssen das
werden wir sehen für uns müsste im
demokratischen spektrum stattfinden das
heißt nicht mit rechts und nicht links
das ist unser anspruch und sollte man
gucken hat zwar grünen pulli an aber es
kommt tatsächlich glücklich dürfen das
erfolgsbeispiel bleiben da geht es um
inhalte und das ist mir heute abend
wirklich zu kurz gekommen haben wir
natürlich geredet weil wir um politische
abgrenzung reden und gefragt haben was
haben wir noch nicht gefragt frage ich
sie noch was hat die csu offensichtlich
früher begriffen als die cdu also die
csu setzt vor allem der letzten zeit auf
die bewahrung der schöpfung und das ist
wichtig das zu tun sie setzt aber eben
darauf auch bayern ein ganz starkes land
zu machen setzen auf modernisierung auf
digitalisierung das werden die
professuren geschaffen und das ist das
was wir für deutschland jetzt brauchen
deswegen schlage ich ja auch vor dass
wir ein gesetzbuch digitalisierung
brauchen was uns fit machte die zukunft
schnellere prozesse auf all diese
fragestellungen kommt dass anderen
ehrlich gesagt möchte ich da nicht hart
aber herzlich darauf verweisen dass
jetzt der andere kollege am start ist
nämlich markus lanz der heute unter
anderem gerhard baum begrüßt und
wolfgang joop wir sehen uns nächste
woche nicht ich erzähle gleich ein
bisschen schneller da fallen wie raus
wegen fasching wenn sie mögen in 14
tagen also wie der gleiche stelle
gleiche welle und vielen dank für die
debatte hier heute abend ist ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]